he knows that coke has become synonymous  with cola and i bet you pepsi  planet earth  i won't just finish my go ahead go ahead  it's a 10 minute point i get it it's  cause i can't make it go ahead good  go ahead  let's be more like them and change the  secret formula to copy  paper and  guess what beat them guess what join  them at a time when i wanted a coke and  they say we like pepsi said no thank you  yeah and you know why you think pepsi is  good because you're a goddamn pothead  burnout who's high all the time who  thinks anything tastes good because  you're higher than i'd rather be a  pothead than a cokehead oh my god you  just said i loved coca-cola baby joe  look at me coca-cola i want you i want  you